United
States is the biggest devil behind all
of this they're just evil today a day of
Rage in the Middle East in other words
it was Wednesday embassies under assault
it was the perfect day for a trip to
Israel the president landed hugged
Netanyahu and then almost fell asleep I
asked the Secretary of State when he and
I are working in the Senate to write
something before man he said uh he wrote
a line that uh I think is
appropriate he said uh it's not we lead
uh not just uh well I won't go into it
I'll wait later taking too much time but
Biden only met with Netanyahu today the
rest of the Arab leaders snubbed them we
give these people billions and they snub
us no respect but after a double
espresso Biden took the podium and In
fairness delivered touching remarks
about what it means to lose a loved one
he said he stands with Israel now and
forever but then he handed the
Palestinians a check for $100 million
today I'm also announcing $100 million
in new US funding for humanitarian
assistance in both Gaza and the West
Bank this money will support more than 1
million displaced and conflict affected
Palestinians including emergency needs
in Gaza if Hamas diverts or steals the
assistance they will have demonstrated
once again that they have no concern for
the welfare of the Palestinian people
and it will end if Hamas steals the
money come on man Biden just bought
terrorists a fresh Arsenal we're a bunch
of suckers what what are the Arabs
giving them nothing the most any Arab
nation is giving the Palestinians $4
million we give him 100 million we're
funding both sides of the war we give
Israel money we give Iran money we give
the Palestinians money Hunter got to be
getting a cut so Biden hugs bbby falls
asleep writes a check to Hamas and then
tells Israel don't turn Gaza into a
quagmire like Bush did in Iraq after
9/11 we were enraged in the United
States
while we sought Justice and got Justice
we also made mistakes I know the choices
are never clear or easy for the
leadership there's always cost but it
requires being deliberate and an honest
assessment about whether the path you're
on will achieve those
objectives the vast majority of
Palestinians are not
Hamas Hamas does not represent the
Palestinian people Biden voted for the
Iraq War and now he's telling Israel
don't be stupid like I was and do your
best to kill terrorists not civilians
thank you Joe great advice he should
have told them don't leave the weapons
behind so terrorists can't have them
like I did in
Afghanistan the president then said our
defense department confirmed that
hamas's rocket hit the hospital not
Israel's yet the president never
mentioned radical Islam he never uttered
a single word about fanatical Muslims
hellbent on ethnic cleansing never
touched it skipped right over the root
causes also never mentioned Iran Biden's
trying to soft pedal Iranian involvement
because his administration has been
letting Iran get away with murder for
years to his credit president Trump had
demolished Isis assassinated solomani
and pulled out of the nuke deal and
slapped crippling sanctions on that
country's energy sector he had great
relationships with the leaders of Saudi
Arabia Egypt Jordan and turkey all the
major Arab players and Israel was
cutting deals with these Arabs and now
the deals are on hold because of Iranian
mischief and Biden isn't going to be
able to put this back together he's just
not Biden was so angry after getting
snub by the Arabs and being greeted with
rockets and riots and hospital hoaxes
that he snapped at binder on the plane
ride home watch you said you were very
blunt with the Israelis on the need to
get humanitarian Aid to Gaza or what
exact L on everything so we we no I I
was very blunt about the need to support
getting humanitarian Aid to Gaza get it
to Gaza and do it quickly all
right any the
hospital don't
oh so prime time isn't really sure what
the trip accomplished symbolically it
was a victory for Israel financially it
was a victory for Hamas
and this obviously delayed Israel's
ground campaign into Gaza the mid East
looks even more chaotic than it did
before Biden irck which is quite the
accomplishment hey Sean Hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to Fox News
YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere
else